i just kind of scan through it briefly
so just let me know what the questions
again so everybody else can hear it
yep so i'm 22 years old just finished uh
university
in the uk and got a graduate job earning
around 45k a year
and i have around 20k and savings i've
watched a lot of your videos and i know
that you
pretty much believe in leaving your
parents house and living by yourself and
living with flatmates and
going through that grind but um what i'm
in at the moment my parents
or my dad says he'll match anything i
put down for my first uh
my first house so ideally in that by
that logic i should have
a deposit down for a place in central
london by um
end of next year but at the moment
living at home i don't have as much
freedom
as i'd like to have in terms of going
out and obviously
seeing girls because i have access to
that i had that in university a high
degree
so i just wanted to know your thoughts
on that
my thoughts are get out of your parents
house and get your own place
um why do you get something that's under
pre-construction right
i mean if you can get something that's
going to close in a year's time you can
put your deposit down you make your
installments on it and then you don't
make your first mortgage payment
i mean that's the way that it works here
anyway but you don't make your first
mortgage payment so you move in and take
possession
at least that way you can get the ball
rolling and start leading up to
something is that something that you can
do
possibly i didn't i'm not sure if that's
a thing in the uk but i can
look into it i mean the reason why i'm
staying at home at the moment is
obviously
corona at the moment locked down and i'm
saving pretty much
90 of my income you've got like full
lockdown scenario
in the uk like we do here right yeah
like
everything's closed but groceries uh
pharmacies like the chemist
um yeah liquor store like that's the
stuff that's open right now
yeah exactly i would still get the hell
out man i mean
like if you want to interact with women
you can still have them come over you
can do stuff outside
i suppose to some degree i mean as long
as the the cops don't see you sitting on
a park bench by the beach like they did
that lady i saw the clip up but
you can get my point i mean like at some
point you're gonna need to get out of
there you can make the excuse of well
there's coronal lock down there's
nowhere to go anywhere and blah blah
blah blah okay fine you know
but what you're really saying is you
know wave a magic wand and solve my
problems so
i can have independents and have these
women and you know basically have it all
but you have some work to do to kind of
set up to that
you're making 45 000 pounds a year yeah
well it's decent money for 22 and you
got 20 grand saved up
yeah so that means your dad will put
another 20 on top of that
yeah well ideally by the end of next
year i'll have at least
45 down closely what does it cost to get
like a one bedroom place
in london where you want to live uh so
i'm looking at around
350k and you need around a 10 deposit
okay you're well on your way to do that
man
okay doesn't sound like you have any
problems going on it sounds like you
just have a
hey hey do you like my idea rich just
kind of salute it let's run it up the
flagpole
yeah no more so if i should leave home
now
and just wait honestly dude the best
thing i ever did was
move out of my parents care and i did it
around
i don't know how old i was 21 22 i think
i was actually in
i was actually in the uk for about three
months and i hated it i
moved back there with my dad and my uh
brother my other brother and my mom
stayed here to kind of wrap up the house
here
but when i came back to canada and got
my own place with a couple of roommates
it was like dude it's it's the best
thing ever like get out of your parents
house
you're gonna have so much flexibility
and and freedom you grow up a lot
quicker right i mean like you're gonna
mature there's a lot of guys out there
today
that are that are um a lot of a lot of
women look
look at a lot of dudes that live at home
into their 20s and 30s as like mama's
boys you know their mom cooks for them
they clean they fold their laundry
all that stuff you want to have some
flexibility and freedom in your life so
not only do you get the freedom but you
also get the respect of your peers once
you get out of that house
yeah i get that you know what i'm saying
okay all right man see ya
thank you
you